it's worth just kind of taking a step
back as well and kind of looking at the
big picture here and when we look at the
big picture you know these are the
numbers these are the different councils
that are being contested of course it is
England we're talking about here
councils in England and you're seeing
the color this makeup of the geography
the political geography of local
government in England starting to change
and I'm going to show you some ways in
which that's changing that really kind
of underline it but one way of just kind
of looking at what's happening right now
and what's happening right now is a
redrawing of the map uh is to look at
these bars here they are giving you a
sense of what's Happening beneath the
surface when you look at counselors
across each of these different areas so
230 different councils about over 8 000
seats so 8 000 councilors and
everything's changing labor is doing
much better so gaining 198 losing 32 the
conservatives look at the conservatives
gaining 24 so it's not all about losses
but then look over here
317 that bar going down into negative
territory and extraordinary net loss for
the Tory party lived down times gaining
107 so lib Downs having another good
good night as well good elections green
party as well so up by 55 for the green
party too but this is pretty clear here
the conservatives not having a very good
time when you look not just at the kind
of at the colors of different uh the
names of the different councils but at
the map across England you can see just
how much that's changing we still have a
lot of kind of light gray areas so areas
where we have yet to have the results
and you see that here look at these 230
202 sorry 2
636 uh seats that we have so far out of
8 000. but when you look at some of the
areas that we're hearing about whether
it's Plymouth there uh in the South uh
West whether it's areas like there's
there's Windsor and maidenhead that's
gone lib Dems as well hasn't it and up
here in the Midlands it's going to be
kind of interesting as well because that
story that we've had recently about
areas which typically when it was the
kind of Blair area when it was new labor
were relatively comfortably labor but
then swung across to the conservative
party party areas like for instance
cannock Chase well up until now this was
conservative it was conservative
controlled but they've lost it they've
lost control of it and when you look at
the lines in terms of this is just
showing you going back to the 90s the
lines of who was in control here it was
the labor party in the 1990s then the
conservatives started to kind of get
back around the 2000s and gain control
gradually recently but now this is what
we're seeing here look at that red line
starting to go up so labor regaining
some influence here and knocking the
Tories out of control of cannock Chase
and that's just one of the many councils
where they are defending okay and here
you have a a kind of board of the areas
where the Tory party are defending these
councils uh there's cannock Chase gone
to no overall control we've arranged
this it's another way of looking at the
same thing we've arranged it by the kind
of marginal swing you need for the
Tories to potentially lose control of
these different councils from areas
where are relatively safe through to
areas where you need a bigger swing for
them to lose it but the Striking thing
is
oh let's take a step back these were all
blue at the start of the counting these
were all conservative councils this
entire board was painted blue and now
just look at it look how much of it is
gray dark gray no overall control look
how much his orange for lip dance yellow
for lip dance look how much is turning
red as well so he's Staffordshire there
but there have been others that have
been further bigger swings to get to
labor party and you're seeing now here
the scale of just how difficult how
tough it has been for the Tory party and
remember as I say we are still only
maybe a quarter getting towards a third
of the way through of the counting and
so far the news has been almost entirely
negative for the conservative party good
for labor good for the lib Dems how good
we'll have to wait and see but really
terrible for Rishi sunak so far